yellow welcome to the video I'm doing a
15 minute video again and then playing
on player from the UK zombie Rogozin
quite a lot of nice name cm all right
let's see what we got here
if you're now ascending so uh play
something else
g3 Yan Knight f3 yeah 93 yeah Black has
a wide range of possibilities here
okay I'm curious I'm trying to be noni
here I don't play this usually but I
feel really sleepy maybe the sir he was
me helps me to wake up a bit okay okay
it's coming follow a fugitive variation
at least I'm most likely not getting
blown off the bottom fianchetto lioness
of course I find choice for for white
but it's um not the kind of line you
usually lose quickly against I don't
know the details here of the theory
though mmm good sharp e8 maybe maybe
also rook e8 this kind of moves are
certainly alright I would put a silver
white also often pledge eight h3 here to
prevent Nagi for at some point okay but
now I think he needs to attend to to
this yeah
with a rook on the ADA also have 95 in
this kind of positions I intended not to
be six here I think this is also
possible maybe I should have thought a
bit longer I what couldn't he'd just
take on d6 here Queen takes Bishop f4
and then yeah maybe okay I think it is
played in this way
sometimes these kind of lines black can
take on a four with the night nine takes
and then be five but at the moment I
think he can you can just take here and
that's maybe not so great
maybe not sure is it an idea to play
Quincy seven year Ruki eight a couple of
couple of yeah normal okay move
but Benoni of course a somewhat
demanding opening you cannot really do
too many second right moves
Quincy seven I don't like rookie a type
of thinking what what what to reply
after Bishop f4 but maybe on this I can
I can protect and then plane at age five
game need to get get going here yeah in
general this kind of opening shouldn't
be too bad for black but it's not the
kind of opening I usually play so need
to arm adjust a bit here I was just
thinking maybe I also could have played
queen Knight to c8 in order to threaten
b5 maybe this would have been an idea
actually
you know I need to take t6 into account
maybe this 127 I don't like yeah I don't
really know what's going on here this
position doesn't really gives me
immediate ideas what to do yes this is
certainly possible but I thought I could
just return to c8 and then maybe go for
b5 that's of course very very much
possible that he's still placed
night-night c4 almost like b5 a ba ba
can also go to a5 maybe a 5c 6s is often
an idea and shows one function of this
Bishop to sort of overprotective five
and support pieces on c6 this is also a
constant issue the b-pawn has moved and
the C pawn has moved like a knight on d4
can often go to c6 yeah it's very
difficult position
he's got some pressure here if he plays
a five which would also look fairly
normal
I can cannot play b5 yeah if he takes
rook takes I have a bit of play or
zombie to that a six seems we come
alright he's doing our solid central
protection and may be planning to to go
to go rookie money five something like
this mmm yeah we'll be 555 play over
maybe it is still so difficult to tell
I can also play moves like Knight h5 -
first of all drive this Bishop back yeah
I think I think I'll go for this first
it's a little bit of annoyance value
also gonna play a for this one is
hanging and G for at least this also
weakening in a way can I can I go before
if he takes I take Knight takes Knight a
takes a but I I can I can check on c3
actually and win a piece then okay maybe
a B this the other night takes I have
night a 7 and that's a deadly pin so I
can I can play me five
yeah if I can play b5 it should be it
should be okay for me his pieces make a
somewhat strange impression here I'm
overlooking something something really
really outstanding here this one an
interesting idea okay yeah uses the fact
that the rook is not protected at the
moment and maybe has this idea of 95 c6
but the diagonal is not open anymore so
it's somewhat less threatening at first
glance
it's still annoying for sure but I have
no night more freely than cc8 night
he has a c8 PCM it was really bad if I
go Knight b6 you might go just 95 but he
could also exchange them play Ruka a7
something like this well it still looks
a bit annoying for me
one issues after night a 5 C 6 & 5
capture this here again D 5 for the c3
night so I need to be careful about this
should I play not be six really
difficult because tonight
II know 95 I could consider night see
for actually this could be an idea if
okay if he takes rook takes I'm not sure
if he has something really super great
then can go on the seventh what I can
just play queen d8 okay they don't need
to play quicker here all night a
five-hour thinking not see for this tech
C 3 and a 5 and so on so he most likely
needs to capture okay he captured them
so now I have exchanged the c4 Knight
against the c8 night this shouldn't be
too bad
the question here one question is can I
get some serious pressure on e4 may be
connected with beef also okay first of
all I'm in a somewhat annoying pin here
should I just returned to to b8 2d ATM
yeah I guess I'll play that it's not
immediately obvious how this might be
refuted okay I need to need to just drop
back know used to look for something
fancy here but this maybe gives me some
some real pressure on you for all right
let's get sharp that's get sharp it's a
it gets sharp now
how interesting
so what if I just say kanji phone with
the bishop doesn't it doesn't this
somehow disturbs peace coordination I
think it would but what about before
before what what what does he play on
before the night moves I just capture
you for what's the trick there don't see
it
don't see why I shouldn't just take next
move on your form
if he tries for some sort of
counter-attack I could I could just take
c3 all right so now just take on a phone
right I really don't see that he has
some trick some trick there if I take on
your phone it could take you for okie
for okay I'd have Ruby eight it's not
obvious no just take it you have some
new flick groups like what d7 or
something but I can just play Queen b8 I
really don't see it I could also take on
d5 actually it's also not bad
but he for really really looks good him
I hope I'm not not overlooking something
totally simple here someone had to
believe that he just just should have
blundered this pawn possible of course
but he's pretty pretty high rated here
okay he's going for some sort of
desperation attack
I could I could not break 93 and rook
rook III trying to break through this
looks looks almost decisive I would say
okay Akiko take on g6 he could take on
g6 maybe what about what about just
Knight to f6 III is hanging and d7 is
hanging he could take take on g6 hg it's
not obvious what what's a big trick
there
I don't see a really satisfactory move
here yeah they can just recapture I
think it's a full working here okay it's
loosely protected by the Queen but III
hanging and this rook is hanging don't
really see what you should do some sort
of sacrifice g5 yeah v3 is also just
hanging I could easily just take on d7
then that's ng5 takes takes and then
some move to protect f7 route p7 for
instance and then III is just just gone
yeah this should be just winning nothing
more nothing less
maybe you could yeah III is old sighing
I was just thinking maybe it takes on f7
and then g5 but the bishop bishop is
just hanging also yeah he played all
those advances g4f for far - yeah really
prematurely far too took quick also I
didn't
well you shouldn't go to extremes either
and spend so much time as I often do
okay this is actually an idea through
k-8 if I capture there
okay do I have some it's a great great
idea
all right what kind of moves could I
could I think of it's still somewhat
annoying through Gaius you cannot take I
cannot remove the night really rugby 7s
also not not great so what should I move
here really could also move the night
but if someone is hanging hmm that's not
so clear everything why I'm just just
not seeing it
of course easily easily possible you
three with the rook look before as an
idea he's not really threatening much
Bishop g5 maybe
hmm I don't see a move here really was
he forum trying to break through the
immediately
time warning yeah I know but I don't see
a move as strange as it may sound Bishop
g5 is annoying all right come on I just
said the Queen eeeh
I have some nice compensation of the
dark squares as long as I don't lose any
any more material here I'm down to 33
seconds maybe I should have done this
far quicker well unless unless I really
lose instantly some some more material
it's it's really ok for me this bishop
here will get a really strong position
yeah there's no more like a bullet game
trying to get some tech going here
- of course somewhat influenced by the
time also I could just take here this
was totally unnecessary
oops he blended the Queen wow what a
game
yeah down to seven seconds
yeah I think miniature white resides
Jesus my yeah talk about being too tired
for a game of chess this looks like
flat-out a winning for black but somehow
somehow I didn't didn't manage share I
don't need to switch the come on quickly
yet it's just too too strange here I can
just take okay a computer also wants to
check here and now rook d7 yeah I was
thinking
rook b7 he would take on and b7 Queen
takes rook f6 I can take his free yeah
but this looks somehow shaky I thought
rook takes Queen takes also Bishop g5
and then he ate is hanging and f6 is
hanging maybe this doesn't matter
Queen 927 maybe yeah the SEC is also I
think so I'm pretty good for black but
if I play this I should should have
should have done this father [ __ ]
I've cost 9 h7 is ridiculous completely
I need to go on H 2 H 5 this also has
already cleared Vantage to black I was
thinking night I cannot go to d7 because
the six is saying
I'm down in 30 seconds also so I was
thinking night h7f 8 and then tried to
prepare 1975 because I thought e5 would
be the right square but Knight h5 is
obviously great I have just the check on
T for any 5 and so on and the night is
not stepping on other other pieces tails
and okay this is also good for black I
can just take on b2 for instance okay
and of course now I lost the thread here
with 30 seconds takes on h4 now yeah
yeah I don't have any time this is equal
according to comp funny he is giving
Brooke be three years the next move rook
b3 b2 am blacks pieces are very active
the knight is protecting the King and
everything else is just as effective so
I wasn't even lost here I thought okay I
just had 15 seconds cm but okay he
blundered his Queen one move maybe was
also Mouse clip I don't know maybe you
wanted to to go Queen d8 I'm not sure
yeah now it's just a question of time
but sorry this was very loud I presume
with lots of pre moves this was supposed
to about 30 moves and in 15 seconds
it's possible yeah thanks for watching
but pretty much pretty messy game but I
was just not awake enough I think [ __ ]
completely correct one okay
till next time bye